Right.
All right.
For the next interval,
we are in the section hosted
by the Active Inference Institute on our
recent paper, active Inference Institute
and the Active Inference Ecosystem. So
two short messages. First,
if you're in the live chat, I'll post
the link right now to the paper. And
this can be more of like a
conversational interval. So if you have
any questions about the
ecosystem or the institute or any
of the stuff that we're talking about,
let's make it a conversation. And then
second message. If there are any co
authors on this paper who are listening
to this stream, then message
me on discord or post in the YouTube
live chat or just check your calendar,
and I expect some others to join in
as we go. Welcome,
Pablo. We'll be hearing in a
little bit from you as a presenter.
Is there anything that you want to just
bring up or reflect on before I share
the screen with the paper and we just
walk through it, explore it and hear
questions?
It okay.
I'll bring in the paper. And again,
anyone watching live, please just feel
free to write any questions,
and I'm just going to bring
it so that Pablo. You're not going to
see the paper, but it's
on the live stream.
All right,
cool.
Well, here we go. This is a paper
that had an awesome co
authorship and even broader circles
beyond the listed co authors of
collaboration and contribution. So just
like everything that has happened and
will happen in our work,
it was massively participatory and
a real learning by doing and a real
enactment moment.
The first version was released three
days ago on Saturday, August 19,
and I'll briefly just list all the
authors. First, we had the institute as
the first author so that the citation
can always remain like institute et al.
Institute, comma active Inference
institute. And we also had Andrea Guire,
John Boyk, Lieber Burian, matthew Brown,
RJ Corday, scott David david S.
Douglas, Pablo Fernandez Macchia,
Daniel Friedman, holly Grimm, Avele
Gwynen, carlo Maria, Louisa Ayenico,
virginia Blue Knight, alexandra
Mikhailova, Ali Ramju Adil Razi, jacob
Smith, rene Tamari, dean Tickles and
Alex Viakin. So this includes everyone
from founders and officers and board of
directors and formal participants on
different projects and different roles
as volunteers or facilitators or
interns, and also people who are
continuing to join the fun and show up
and makes the institute in our field
what it is and what it can be, what we
want it to be.
There's a table of contents for those
who like to click through. And just
broadly, there's going to be a preamble
on active inference. But outside of the
preamble, this paper is not conceptual,
it is not technical, it is not
philosophical, although perhaps it can
be read in all of those ways, but it's
quite a logistical, historical,
and vision oriented position document.
After getting some of the active
inferences out of the way in the
preamble. We're going to turn to the
institute itself in terms of our vision,
values, principles, and how we see
moving through the challenges that we're
facing right now onto the specific
history of the institute, our current
organization model in terms of our
governance and leadership structure, as
well as the institute units, the
organizational units that support all
the work we do. We then turn out
to the community and ecosystem growth
and development and go through some
details of different roles that
our stakeholders and participants in our
space and some of the tools that we use
today for managing information and
message passing. We talk a little bit
about our communications plan, internal
and external, both sides of the blanket,
and point towards some of the types of
support, infrastructure and
administration that we do and that we
will offer for the active inference
ecosystem. We frame that in terms of
continual deployment, continual
development and quality, performance and
growth evaluations across multiple
scales, close with some discussion and
then provide an appendix that overviews
a variety of the open source services
that the Institute has provided over the
past. So let's just jump in. I'm
actually going to jump into the open
source services first and overview them
before we jump back up to the top and
look at the big picture. Because this is
really to appreciate the work of so many
contributors who stepped up in
the uncanny valley, in the gray zone,
in the ecosystem, as it's forming, as
it's always forming, and really made it
happen. And so many people we know are
out there scribbling or taking notes or
printing out papers by Friston at all or
struggling and asking questions, are
there applications of this? How would
this matter? Why would this matter? Is
there a code version of this? How do you
connect the dots between these? Like,
those are what we ask every day. And so
when people can combine their regimes of
attention into a synthetic intelligence
outcome, then we go so far.
So the first category of works that the
Institute has developed are educational.
We've done video live streams since the
end of 2020. Till now, more than 370
live streams. All live streams are
curated in terms of their transcript.
And we increasingly are developing
automated and semiautomated methods for
transcription, translation, sub,
captioning, language modeling and so on.
We've had textbook groups actually.
Now, as of now, we have three completed
cohorts of the active inference textbook
group, the 2022 textbook.
We have two courses that are being
offered that are produced by external
content developers, and both of these
have only started in the last three,
four months. First is Chris Fields's,
physics is Information Processing, and
second is the work spearheaded by Avel
and co organized with Kairos Research,
active inference in the social sciences.
Both of these are like awesome and great
learning experiences, as we heard from
earlier in the symposium. We're working
with Sanjeev Namjoshi on his incredible
textbook, although almost to call it a
textbook is to either think more broadly
about textbooks than one has or
constrain what it really is that he's
doing, because it's such a unique, real
research development, full spectrum
effort. So I'm really looking forward to
seeing how this plays out in 2024.
Until then, for those who want to get
involved with the testing that we do and
we've developed the Active Inference
Ontology, which is a critical resource
for the ecosystem. It enables us to
center accessibility, rigor and
applicability across languages and
settings by knowing what it is that
we're talking about when we talk about
active inference. On the research side,
we've also developed the Ontology in a
research direction in terms of research
on and about and with active inference
itself. As far as software goes, our
primary development, first off, has been
the documentation and connecting the
dots around some of these other
incredible packages that others are
developing. For example, just in this
symposium, we've heard from some of the
core developers and open source
contributors to Pymdp, the Python
package for generative modeling, as well
as just a couple of minutes ago from
Bert de Fryes and Dmitry Bagueev coming
from the Julia language RX and FIR side.
And both of those are some of the
leading packages for applying active
inference. So we do a lot of work to
connect those dots and make it more
accessible. Not everybody is going to
jump in with all 6ft to a programming
language. And what we've done with
Active Blockfriends, with the work of
Jacob Smekal and others, is to wrap
generative models from active inference
inside of the complex systems modeling
framework Catcat. We've developed
notation interoperability systems that
actually let us pull back one layer from
the implementational details themselves,
for example, of RX infer or of Pymdp,
so that we can bring it halfway to
where the ontology and the visualization
and the natural language exists, and
then use language models and other
techniques to deploy it in an
implementation fashion. We've developed
a host of research publications. We
support people in all of their different
stages of their career, different
seasons of life, and some really
creative work has been directly produced
through an institute project or somebody
who knows may have gotten good ideas or
good feedback just by hanging out,
being in the game. And we performed
literature metaanalyses to help grapple
with the scope and the quantity and the
quality of what is unfolding before our
eyes or before our antenna. Again, even
as we only so partially sample this
ocean of information, we're active in
standard setting and continue to develop
our qualification standards for active
inference that could be the basis of
education, research and professional
development. We provide a variety of
mentorship and facilitation service type
activities, including volunteer program,
internship program, distributed
facilitation, and applied active
inference symposia. These activities,
just as all others that we're describing
above, are open source, and they're also
open to your participation. So if you
can follow some of those suggestions by
JF time boxing and prioritize and pay
attention and be active, all those fun
things that he said, and you're looking
to do it in a semi structured way with a
volunteer program, or in a more
structured way with the internship,
then I heartily encourage people to get
involved. Act now. And in
terms of governance activity, we have
a scientific advisory board as well as a
board of directors. And together with
the officers, those groups constitute
the formal governance structure of the
Institute. But there's also so much more
to it, and we look forward to
understanding what ecosystem governance
can look like in the coming years. So
welcome, Dean. I just summarized the
work itself. That was the preamble.
And now if you'd like to say hi, you or
Pablo, before we jump into more sections
of the paper or look at more questions
that people have asked, how goes it? Or
what was your experience of working with
the paper? Or what brings you onto this
strange stream at this opportune time?
Basically why I'm here is because for
the first time, even as an acting
board member with the Institute, I was
able to get a better sense of
the kind of depth that we aspire to.
And I'm not sure whether or not we
are going to be I really don't know what
directions we're going to be going in
the next coming months, weeks, years,
et cetera. But I have a better sense
now, as a result of participating in
this development exercise,
of what the potential is than I probably
had at any time. And I've been with the
Active Inference Institute for a couple
of years, so that's saying something. I
think we had to get to this point to be
able to write this document, and now
it's acting as a bit of a springboard
now which way we go and how we land.
I'm not still certain about what that
looks like, but I think that's part of
what the really interesting thing is.
We seem to have moved away from the
dock, and now the real journey begins.
So that's my take on it so far.
Moving away from the dock, dock pushing
off, using it as a springboard,
continuing the adventure, leaving the
preprint behind, continuing to version
it as a living document and also
wayfinding outside of the doc. Pablo.
Oh, wait, I don't hear you yet. Pablo.
Sorry, I was mute. Hello. It was
a great experience to go through the
document and review it and reread it and
thinking about it. Actually, it's a
living document, which is super
exciting, and I keep taking notes and
hopefully act on it in the
future. And it's been
a super experience to find
so many people with the same interest,
same interest and some
values that I really think are going
to be the basis of organizations on the
future. So I think we are doing
something very cool here.
Cool. All right, well, let's just walk
through some of the sections in the 25
minutes that we have. Again, the paper
is being shown on the stream, but Dean
And probably don't see it. So we
kicked off with a preamble. We wanted to
introduce active inference as briefly as
we could and point towards the
fundamental first principles and physics
based nature of active inference and
initially point towards its integrative
capacity in principle. And then in the
second paragraph, there's about 104
citations in this paragraph. And that's
where it's really only a sampling of
the domains, 21 domains here.
So it's a place where we can point to
where is active inference being applied,
or how is active inference being
applied, or how is it different or
better than another approach in a given
setting? Which isn't to say that it does
everything in all settings for all
people at all times and all of that,
but this is to say that here's where one
can look to find out more and even just
building. This and bringing it all
together. We see so many opportunities
for epistemic resources in the ecosystem
and having real time literature analyses
and all these kinds of services that we
want to provide.
Starting on page five, we turn to the
institute itself and we
write as of August 2023, the Active
Inference Institute is a registered
nonprofit organization tasked with
identifying, establishing, and managing
the sustainable implementation of
administrative and governance functions
to give components of the active
inference ecosystem coherent forms and
reliable channels of communication.
Two, publishing and licensing protocols
that establish open and fair use and
effective dissemination of community
products within and beyond the
ecosystem. Three, services at the scale
of individual humans and the community
at large so that stability is protected
while risk and uncertainty are minimized
within the ecosystem. And four,
organization and operation of cyber and
cognitive security systems that ensure
productivity, inclusivity accessibility,
and safety in discourse. In
collaboration, figure one gives
a graphical representation, just one of
how we are now. And for those who
want to dig more, check out the 2022
Active Inference textbook where you'll
also find a golden ring. And we kind of
took that graphical motif and ran with
it. Had a lot of fun and a lot of
interpretations there. So just here
looking at figure one, Dean or Pablo
just want to add anything?
Yeah, Dean.
So one thing about the building
of this document with a whole bunch
of authors,
it's often not made explicit,
but there are two aspects to learning
about yourself. One is to actually throw
some stuff down on paper because you
believe certain things need to be
included. And then the second part is
the consolidation process. And I think
one of the most interesting
consolidation processes was this
graphic, because I think what it does is
it tries to condense as
much as possible and yet still remain
coherent around what the relational
aspects that we are trying to
make available are, as opposed to, this
is what we've captured. Now look
what our graphic designer came up with.
So if you've had a chance to kind of
look at this and really analyze it and
think about the layers and think about,
okay, so what's the background here?
What's the foreground? Does this
representation allow for a swapping?
Can we have things that appear to be
background or fundamental basis
stuff that could actually be things that
we are addressing in the moment versus
those things which we look at as
particulars, that, in fact, are
generalities? So, again, it's one of
those things. I don't know. Daniel
probably knows whether it's a Where's
Waldo's thing or some sort of artist
that came up with some strange twist on
things. But the bottom line is, spend a
few minutes, have a look, because you'll
want to go through your own building of
what these relationships are, and you'll
also want to be able to consolidate. I
wasn't there when this representation
was built, but I do know that I want to
be able to both look at it, do a
comparative analysis to what I think the
Institute should be, and then be able to
consolidate.
Awesome. Yeah. Just a few notes on this
and to give a visual overview, since it
may be clearer to see this than go
through the prose that essentially
describes it as much later on. The
golden ring represents the active
inference ecosystem, and I think we
could talk about golden rings for a long
time to come. But coming in from the
ecosystem on the bottom bottom
for the reader, not from the other side
of the table, are the projects. And all
the projects are participatory
endeavors. They're happening behind,
on, and in front of the golden ring,
depending on how you look at it. And
that is the appendix and all of those
different projects that we talked about
and all of the iterations and new
threads that I know that we're going to
see in an hour and I know that we're
going to see in a month and in a year
and in a century. And those projects
are being supported through two
units, kind of like a department, but an
organizational unit, one centered on
education and one centered on research.
The education unit is called Educe, and
the research unit is called Reinforce.
So right there you kind of have active
inference, in case that wasn't clear
coming from the Institute scale.
Supporting the unit scale are a variety
of functions such as funding and
partnerships, communications and
hierarchical processes such as the
construction of enabling systems. And at
the institute scale, other than
administrative functions. We have the
officers, the day to day operators of
the work, the board of directors, which
is the formal governing body, and the
scientific advisory board where we
really want to call out broadly and have
people who may have or may have not
thought that they would find themselves
in a scientific advisory board, for
example, in 2024. This is your
invitation. And we really want to have a
vibrant scientific advisory board who
serves liaison type roles with different
sectors and just gives periodic,
super valuable, high leverage insight.
And then, I guess, depending on how you
think about it, as all things we have
just a few terms. They don't just
represent bricks in the wall, but it's
more of like the
fibers we weave. And some of these are
already things that we do every day
courses, educational groups, events,
live streams, ontology research. Others
of these are things that we know will be
coming into place in the coming years
and we know that the tapestry is just
going to continue to expand. So it's
really exciting. On Page Six,
we have another figure and this is just
another way to represent some of the
functions that we serve in the
ecosystem. This isn't the only or the
final or a fixed representation of the
functions that we have or the only way
to slice and dice or any of that, but
just to connect some of the dots between
the functions that we do and want to
serve for the ecosystem. So starting
from the broadest, let's just say where
the listener is, where you are right now
is in the space of awareness. And that
happens through communication. Some
people who become aware through a search
or a language model or a video
suggestion or a friend or happenstance
or synchronicity or however, some
fraction of the aware will pursue
education. And about education we
have and will continue to produce the
materials, documentation ontology
courses, live streams and so on.
Education is produced and rests upon
a commons. It's an epistemic commons.
It's a verified information environment.
And that is really the space. The
wildlife preserve, as I know Dean likes
to refer to it not jokingly at
all. And underneath the commons is the
support that does sit between
a participatory commons and a formal
governing kernel. That support in the
coming years may go many directions,
but we know it's going to involve all of
our favorite things like hardware,
software, information, behavior,
narrative, and more. And then we have
the regular institute scale
governance, partnership sponsor and
donor relationships such that we can
first find a type of stability or
sustainability and then more actively
play a regenerative role in our
ecosystem. We want to dispense micro
grants to people and we want to explore
paid internships and be able to meet
people where they are in their active
inference journey. And things
have been happening to that end and
through many means since 2021.
On page six. Pablo or Dean want to add
any thoughts?
I'm super excited about the governance,
the education on the game and tools.
In an hour we're going to see the first
active inference game. This is very fun.
On seven, we describe our vision,
our values and our principles. And just
to read the top level on the values and
principles, they are active inference
and exploration, integrity and
inclusivity, dynamic internal modeling,
anticipatory behavior, and continuous
development. On page eight,
we talk about some priorities and
challenge areas. These are challenges
across multiple scales. They're
challenges that individual people face
in their journey to learn and apply in
so many different backgrounds. These are
challenges of national interest. These
are challenges of global emergency as
well. These challenges are educational
in nature, for example, related to
scientific literacy and workforce
development and just general
professionalization in changing times.
On the research side, there are some
priorities and challenge areas related
to the fundamentals of cognitive science
and grounding the cognitive science in
physics, getting that integrative first
principles framework that we expect and
prefer about information science and
diverse intelligences. Things are faster
and different than they have been, and
active inference is perfectly poised for
sense making and decision making in that
space. User experience,
accessibility, and sociotechnical
design. This is a major open question
across different settings, so it's not
uniquely held to the institute.
However, we really do believe and really
will commit to exploring new kinds of
ergonomics and onboardings and
experience so that we can come
through and be how we want to be.
From the first time somebody enters the
game. Where we can highlight
accessibility, meeting people in the
language that they prefer to listen to
and speak at the language, in computer
language or at the math level that
reflects somebody's preference in that
moment as well as being able to use
augmented and synthetic intelligence
systems to ramp up and even push the
frontier of what augmented people and
other kinds of collective intelligence
systems can do. Cyber and cognitive
security, these also are broader
topics. We've worked on these topics
from an active inference perspective.
Many have. And we think that this is
going to become increasingly relevant as
things do become more and more
challenging and uncertain in certain
ways out there. Scaling the active
inference ecosystem we've heard about
this from the narrow and technical side.
We had estimates of the computational
complexity of sophisticated inference
about how many computer operations have
to happen for a given calculation to
play out. And that's sometimes called
scaling. Active inference, like, okay,
it took 1 minute on 1GB of data, so how
many minutes is it going to take on this
computer with this much data? Scaling
the active inference ecosystem, though,
is a broader question, and that's where
we come to more of the social fabric and
the real sense of belonging that we all
want to have and co create and provide
for others in the ecosystem. And so this
kind of scaling is really
transdisciplinary. It's really skin in
the game. It's as real as it gets.
And applying active inference, some
applications we've heard from today,
some applications are cited in the early
pages of this paper, and more and more
come through every day, and we support
at the Institute various applications of
active inference. Dean, what can you add
in there?
Okay, my mute is off. Good. So here's
something that never came up in the
writing of the document, but I think
it's kind of interesting, and I'm
curious what you guys have to think
about this.
175 years ago, an institution came and
formed together. It's called the
Smithsonian Institute. Now, I don't know
if 175 years from this conversation
today, they'll be the equivalent of
whatever the Active Inference Institute
is 175 years forward,
but I think it's okay to start thinking
in those terms. It doesn't mean that we
follow in their footsteps, necessarily,
but I think it means that we have a long
term view and that the things that we
write about ourselves now have some
shelf life, have some real sense
of, well, there are things that
we can and we cannot change. But if you
look at the front page, the landing page
of the Smithsonian Institute, the first
thing that they say is welcome, which is
what we say about the Active Inference
Institute. And then they say, the
Smithsonian Institution is the world's
largest museum education and research
complex. We are a community of learning
and an opener of doors. Join us on a
voyage of discovery.
So in three sentences, they kind of sum
themselves up, what's the formula for
not just existing for 175 years,
but being a force?
And I think, again,
Daniel, whatever you decide to highlight
in the document today, what I think
we're really trying to do is say, do the
words that we put out now, will they
continue to resonate with people for
decades to come? And again, I don't want
to sound all hand wavy, but I want to
hold up an example of a place that
really did set itself up to be something
that people could return to again and
again and again. And I don't think
there's anything wrong with aspiring to
having that kind of place, that kind
of respect. And I think that the things
that you're pointing to right now,
hopefully we're
preparing properly. So that's
what I'm taking away at this point.
We know about that preparation
measurement cycle from Chris Fields,
don't we? Yeah.
We go on, talk a little. Oh, yeah.
Please, Pablo. Go. No, no, definitely.
I completely agree. I've been thinking
about that for a long time.
You want to build and act for
the best of the future, and I think to
reflect that on the paper, it's super
important. Yeah, definitely up
to do that. Yeah,
way ahead. We describe some paths that
we want to take and the history of the
Institute. We describe our origins. But
I actually wanted to come to figure
three and four on page eleven to speak
to building one of the most amazing and
encouraging things has been the all
ages, all time zone, active build,
contribute mindset.
An earlier version of myself, I might
have thought, like people who do
variational Bayesian methods in machine
learning, they're going to have no issue
onboarding to active inference. It's
just going to be like as simple as
saying, yeah, it's a variational
Bayesian model with action. So it's just
signal processing on the inbound. It's
just control theory on the outbound.
But if you're familiar with variational
Bayes and variational free energy, this
isn't changing it that much. Oh, yeah,
we use a particular partition and it's
related to the free energy principle.
But don't worry too much, you'll get
there. I thought that that would be the
path for so many and future
analyses will reveal what they do or
don't reveal, but what we found in
our enacted work as
it really played out that there was
inclusion and unique contributions to
conversations ranging from philosophy of
science to fundamentals of statistics
and metascience and the role of
quantitative studies and social systems.
All these amazing topics and people
who just scampered so rapidly
through what
could be seen as prerequisite from a
disciplinary perspective was facilitated
by the recognition that one was already
in the space and in the way that they
needed to be to be an active inference.
And that was not written out before
and even now the traces are barely
recorded, but it will become to be
understood more fully.
And to your point, Daniel, I think
especially what the pie chart shows is
the actual spectrum aspect of
this. So I know that right now that
maybe the neuroscience and the
psychology piece take up a bigger
portion. But I think one of the things
that we're trying to promote is the idea
that you can come from just about
any background as opposed to, oh,
all paths lead to, as you said, an
earlier version of you said, oh, okay,
well, I can see where everything is
going to where the confluence is going
to. No, I think what this demonstrates
is that it's actually becoming more
distributed the longer we
continue to exist.
Yeah, this figure, of course, I'm super
happy with everything that we were able
to do, but this figure is almost a
little bit like a
paper target that we're just going to
blow out later. Because it was a
fraction of only people who had
formal affiliations listed, which means
only people for whom we had done full
literature based pulling up their
information. So it doesn't even
represent the actual participation
profile. This is more like the
invitation list for live streams.
So we are going to see another
long tail that covers
the part that's not the long tail. I
believe the
rest of the paper continues along
possibilities, challenges, next steps,
more about the institute organization,
various other pieces of information that
potentially eager stakeholders or
participants or donors or liaisons or
other people would like to learn more
about. It's there to engage with. We
want people to hop into our discord and
continue the conversation or email us or
otherwise get involved. It's why we
called this symposium enacting
Ecosystems of Shared Intelligence at
the, of course, relevant suggestion of
Karl Friston, because we really do want
to enact it. So if you feel like you're
on the sideline waiting to jump in or
you're on the beach and people are out
there surfing the 100 foot wave, then
maybe it's time to get more involved.
So I will leave the closing word first
to Dean, then Pablo, and then we'll go
to Raph's presentation.
Well, just real quick, again, if you
want a consolidated document that speaks
to the now but also points to a
direction that none of us really know is
certain, but is also really exciting,
have a look at the doc.
Pablo?
Yeah. I'm here to make
sure that I act as one
of those people of all backgrounds and
perspectives that has taken advantage
through one year of learning and working
on this institute, and hopefully see you
in 1 hour. So thank you and
have fun. Thanks. Awesome. Thank you.
Thank you, Dean. Thank you, Pablo.
Welcome, Raf, also author on the paper.